[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est stressant
il ya une chose que la société nous a
appris depuis qu'on est petit cette
chose c'est qu'il ya des gens qui
réussissent
d'un côté et à des gens qui ne
réussissent pas de l'autre côté
est ce qu'il ya des gens ici parmi voix
auxquelles on a dit depuis qu'ils sont
petits qui sont destinés à réussir si on
a levé la main s'il vous plaît est ce
qu'il ya des gens auxquels on a dit
qu'ils sont destinés à échouer
il y en a qu'un seul ok il y en a quand
même un peu donc voilà chacun a une
certaine idée du succès on se dit le
succès c'est ceci le succès c'est cela
et on se dit voilà je veux réussir dans
ma vie tout le monde se dit je veux
réussir dans ma vie n'est-ce pas tout ce
qui se dit je vais réussir le bel abbès
s'il vous plaît ok tout le monde est
avec moi tout le monde de réussir
voilà donc ce qu'on va faire on va
penser ensemble à la définition du
succès qu'est ce que le succès lorsqu'on
me demande
ulrich d'après toi c'est quoi réussir
j'ai du mal à répondre quand j'étais
petit j'étais toujours le premier de la
classe et les gens me disaient ullrich
c'est sûr que tu vas réussir et j'étais
content et je continue à être premier de
la classe et avait des gens de l'autre
côté qui visait une riche c'est vrai que
tu es promis en classe mais le succès à
l'école ne veut pas dire que tu vas
réussir dans la vie
et j'avais peur et je tremblais c'était
vraiment effrayant parce que je me
disais malgré tous les efforts que je
fais il se peut que je ne réussisse pas
mais je n'ai toujours pas la définition
du succès ce qu'on a fait on va regarder
la quête de personnes qui ont réussi
on va voir si dans leur visage on peut
voir si enfin ce que c'est que le succès
lorna bill gates l'homme le plus riche
du monde depuis deux décennies je pense
ensuite on a dit caroline est l'auteur
du livre harry potter qui est le lit le
plus vendu de l'histoire
ils étaient vendus à plus de 400
millions de copies et elle est aussi
milliardaire coming et ensuite on à
cristiano ronaldo
certaines personnes disent qu'il est le
meilleur joueur du monde
d'autres personnes ne seront pas du tout
d'accord ok donc là ça fait trois
personnes trois contemporain qui sont
des personnes qu'on considère comme des
modèles de réussite mais est ce que vous
pouvez me dire on les regarde en
regardant
l'histoire quelque ce qu'ils ont d'eux
qu'on meurt c'est difficile à dire
j'espère ok on va aller alors chercher
dans l'histoire le suivant on n'avait
pas encore de photos à cette époque donc
vous aurez une structure censée socrates
quand on parle de philosophie on pense
tous à socrate
mais il n'était pas un milliardaire
comme bill gates n'était pas
milliardaires comme jk rowling même s'il
a peut-être écrit des livres que
certaines personnes vous pensez qu'ils
ont eu plus d'influencé sur l'histoire
mondiale que harry potter ensuite on
avant de drogue
quelqu'un que tous ses contemporains ont
considéré comme un fou c'était quelqu'un
qui était complètement maîtrisé pourtant
après sa mort quelques dizaines d'années
après les gens se sont rendu compte que
les peintures qui l'avait fait qu'il
faisait qu'on pensait qu'il était fou
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
et aujourd'hui ces peintures sont parmi
les peintures qui coûte le plus cher
dans le monde
on a plusieurs de ces pays -turquie
coûte 100 millions de dollars et
beaucoup d'autres qui coûte des dizaines
de millions de dollars
je dirais qu'il est devenu riche après
sa mort
mais je ne sais pas est ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous allez tous envie
de devenir
devenir riche après votre mort qui
s'intéresse ici personne ok donc là on
voit que les personnes qui ont réussi ce
sont des personnes qui viennent de tous
les horizons
on voit que le succès ce n'est pas avoir
beaucoup d'argent à socrate n'avait pas
beaucoup d'argent
le succès ce n'est pas être aimé par
tout le monde parce que van gogh n'était
pas aimé par tout le monde
de son vivant le succès c'est beaucoup
plus que ça le succès c'est pas des
personnes non plus on n'a rien eux
n'auront naldo qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
si on vous disait un monsieur qu'on
appelle cristano ronaldo s'ils ne
jouaient pas au football et cetera
personne ne le connaîtraient pas ce que
c'est pas cristiano ronaldo qu'on aime
mais c'est ce que cristiano ronaldo
incarne ce qu'il fait donc le succès ce
sont avant tout des idées ce sont des
idées qui peuvent changer le monde
lorsque vous parlez à des personnes qui
sont aujourd'hui parmi les personnes qui
ont le plus de succès dans le monde
lorsque vous demandez à max bieber qui a
créé facebook
qu'est ce qu'il a envie de faire de sa
vie il va vous dire je vais changer le
monde
lorsque vous demandez à landes mu qui
essayent maintenant d'envoyer des gens
sur mars il le fait pour aussi changer
le monde dont le succès c'est d'abord
créer une idée qui peut changer le monde
maintenant une idée c'est juste une idée
une idée ça peut rester dans ma tête et
ne jamais en sortir une idée je peux la
partager avec vous mais quand vous serez
partie où ils auraient déjà oublié
n'est ce pas ok donc l'idée seul ne fait
pas non plus le succès je me disais il
ya quelques années que si je pouvais
créer des choses extraordinaires
je serai quelqu'un qui a du succès j'ai
beaucoup travaillé j'ai créé des choses
extraordinaires
d'après ce que les gens disent et je ne
dirais pas que je suis satisfait de ce
que j'ai crié
parce qu'il manque quelque chose
il manque les personnes créé une idée
oui c'est bon on crée des idées qui
changent la vie des gens qui changent la
vie de personnes dans votre ville
dans votre village de personnes autour
de vous mais ceux qui ont le plus de
succès ce sont ces personnes là qui
arrive à avoir ces idées qui changent la
vie de millions de milliards de
personnes pouvoir créer ces idées qui
changent l'humanité donc d'après moi
c'est ça le succès et j'aimerais
partager avec vous mon nivea mois après
avoir réfléchi sur toute ma carrière
professionnelle je suis dit ulrich
j'ai besoin de cette idée là cette idée
qui va te guider dans l'avenir et j'ai
fait une rétrospective et je me suis dit
qu'est-ce qui a allié
tout ce que je fais jusque là lorsque
j'ai commencé c'était il ya dix ans j'ai
commencé tout seul dans ma chambre ou
dans ainsi des rats programmé à créer
des choses que les personnes à l'autre
bout du monde
utilisez donc mon idée à moi c'est que à
partir de là prit pas seulement
l'afrique mais un peu partout dans le
monde où que vous soyez dans le monde
vous pouvez créer quelque chose qui peut
changer le monde c'est mon idée à moi et
ça ce que j'essaie de partager dans
chacune de l'asie l'initiative et
j'aimerais vous demande
et à vous pensez-y quelle est votre idée
avoue c'est ce que j'aimerais vous
demander
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]